♪ Starry, starry night ♪
♪ Paint your palette blue and gray ♪
♪ Look out on a summer's day ♪
♪ With eyes that know
the darkness in my soul ♪
♪ Shadows on the hills ♪
♪ Sketch the trees and daffodils ♪
♪ Catch the breeze and winter chills ♪
♪ In colors on the snowy linen land ♪
♪ Now I understand ♪
♪ What you tried to say to me ♪
♪ And how you suffered for your sanity ♪
♪ And you how tried to set them free ♪
♪ They would not listen,
they did not know how ♪
♪ Perhaps they'll listen now ♪
♪ For they could not love you ♪
♪ But still your love was true ♪
♪ And when no hope was left in sight ♪
♪ On that starry, starry night ♪
♪ You took your life, as lovers often do ♪
♪ But I could've told you, Vincent ♪
♪ This world was never meant
for one as beautiful as you ♪
(gentle guitar music)
(audience applauding and cheering)